this is read not coming true now they
are back this time here said Russell
Esther the spectacular Duncan it's a
two-point game
water to the rim who teaches this guy
the top of his shell folks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
emphatic
6:3
[Music]
[Applause]
with nuclear athleticism Russell
Westbrook
[Music]
27 the Nikoli once 21 has been cut to 2
[Applause]
as we approach a minute remaining
yeah no fouls to give for the Knicks
Westbrook on the drive get to the paint
dries to keep the lapis curve
the lead is cut to 1 but the Nixon take
that you take them going for the two
rather than the three
they leave again Westbrook's flying back
now it's Hansen side gets to Robinson
back out power Barrett for Trey
[Applause]
Covington
there comes Westbrook they got
let's put picks it out - coming - up top
- Harden
[Applause]
on the drive we missed it
and the next grab the rebound Randall
seconds of the night hardness missed the
park blade raised layer seven seconds
difference between shot clock and game
clock so obviously the Rockets do not
have to fat but they needn't stop
five out of twenty four areas in the
drive home
watching his team
Tony calls timeout as Barrett times his
career-high were 27
what fortitude an aptitude by the
neophyte previously straight a hard
wooden loop downtown
but now
manipulating
as stated up they tried to preserve his
victory put a Knicks tonight the 19 year
old rookie will the superb performance
tonight flux shot here to give the
Knicks of three-point lead
unikz president Lian Rose pumps his fist
general manager Scott Perry Rockets
still have a timeout
drives
a foul called on militina so Westbrook
will shoot two free-throws with 5.5
remaining that's just as good as what
the Knicks he wanted to do he wanted to
give to five monic mike miller might
challenge this
you know that looked like a clean stroke
after he deflected the ball with another
challenging at Westbrook hits the first
so now a two-point game would Westbrook
try to miss this one Mike and try to get
the rebound well they still have a
timeout remaining so they don't really
need to do that to it because they can
advance the ball of the timeout West
blog lineage hits it hard again and the
lead is one coming to NASA
[Applause]
Westbrook against Neil Akina
drives pawn shops up and the next way
[Applause]
skip some victory in his first day as
president of the Knicks the Knicks upset
the Houston Rockets that snap a mountain
what about the neuropathy
beautiful
one of his best games as a Knick
offensively and that vexing defense
there on Westbrook making him come up
short
Frank are you bothered by these up
anybody's up forcing Westbrook to its
left and he's able to harass the shot
and the Knicks prevail of course in what
has been a tough season this is one of
the highlight nights thrilling victory
for the knick fans here in the garden
they defeat a rocket team that came in
having won six in a row good play to
start to do ten here RJ parent Titus
career I were 27-6
Knicks make that seven Knicks in double
figures in scoring